GOOD EVENING ON MIKE EMANUEL IN
FOR BRET BAIER.
THERE ARE NEW WORRIES TONIGHT
OVER THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION, A CONSERVATIVE
WRITER AND ASSOCIATE OF TRUMP
LAWYER ROGER STONE SAYS HE'S
TALKING ABOUT A PLEA DEAL.
AND EXACTLY WHAT CORSI KNOWS AND
WHAT IT MEANS FOR THE PRESIDENT
TONIGHT.
IT'S NOT GOOD NEWS FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
CORRESPONDENT KEVIN CORKE IS
OUTSIDE THE FLORIDA RESORT
TONIGHT.
>> JEROME CORSI IS NOT DIRECTLY
TIED TO PRESIDENT TRUMP BUT HE
IS AN ASSOCIATE OF ROGER STONE
WHO IS A TRUMP ADVISOR BACK IN
2016.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS HE CONTINUES
TO POSSIBLY CREATE A SITUATION
THAT COULD LEAD TO A PLEA DEAL,
CERTAINLY THAT IS NEWSWORTHY AND
I THINK EVERYONE CAN AGREE, IT
MAY NOT BE VERY GOOD NEWS FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
>> President Trump: THE
WRITTEN ANSWERS TO THE
WITCH HUNT THAT'S BEEN GOING ON
FOREVER, NO COLLUSION, NO
NOTHING, THEY'VE BEEN FINISHED.
>> WHILE THE PRESIDENT REMAINS
STEADFAST IN HIS DENIAL OF ANY
COLLUSION, THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
OFFICE CONTINUES TO TIGHTEN THE
NET ON A NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO WERE CLOSE TO THE TRUMP
ORBIT.
THE LATEST, JEROME CORSI WHO
LIKE ROGER STONE HAS BEEN LINKED
TO THE CONTROVERSIAL WEBSITE
INFOWARS AND HAS BEEN IN TALKS
ABOUT A PLEA DEAL STEMMING FROM
THE RUSSIA PROBE.
IF THE TEAM QUESTIONED HIM,
MUELLER IS TRYING TO DETERMINE
WHETHER STONE AND OTHER
ASSOCIATES HAD ADVANCE KNOWLEDGE
OF WIKILEAKS PLANS TO RELEASE
DAMAGING CLINTON EMAILS DURING
THE CAMPAIGN.
IF A PLEA DEAL IS AGREED TO,
CORSI WOULD JOIN A HALF DOZEN
OTHERS CONVICTED BY THE MUELLER
TEAM.
THOUGH NONE OF THEM HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED.
THE NEWS REVERBERATED AROUND
WASHINGTON, THE PRESIDENT IN
FLORIDA KEPT HIS FOCUS ONLINE ON
THE ONGOING CRISIS AT THE BORDER
WHERE THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS HAVE
COLLECTED HOPING TO PUSH THEIR
WAY INTO THE U.S. BY WAY OF
ASYLUM.
THE INSTALLATION OF MILES OF
RAZOR WIRE TO THE HOURS LONG
SHUTDOWN OF ONE PORT OF ENTRY,
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
REBUFFED THE EFFORT.
INSTEAD APPLYING PRESSURE ON
MEXICO.
WHERE THERE IS INCREASING
PRESSURE TO MOVE THE MIGRANTS IN
ONE DIRECTION OR THE OTHER.
>> President Trump: YOU HAVE
TO HAVE BORDERS.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE BORDERS, YOU
DON'T HAVE A COUNTRY.
IF WE FIND IT GETS TO A LEVEL
WHERE WE ARE GOING TO LOSE
CONTROL, WE WILL CLOSE ENTRY
INTO THE COUNTRY INTO A PERIOD
OF TIME UNTIL WE CAN GET IT
UNDER CONTROL.
>> CRITICS MAY REJECT THE
POLICIES BUT THE PRESIDENT ON
TWITTER SEEMS CONTENT TO PASS
THE PROBLEMS
ON REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS TO
COME TOGETHER, ADDING THAT AFTER
40 YEARS OF TALK IT'S FINALLY
TIME FOR ACTION.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT CORSI MIGHT
PLEAD GUILTY TO OR OFFER A PLEA